el presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
defendió a su ministro de defensa Iván
Velázquez y dice que hay una persecución
penal contra él por combatir la
corrupción en Guatemala pero el
presidente guatemalteco Alejandro yamaté
ya respondió y dice que es una
investigación judicial sin tintes
políticos pero realmente qué hay detrás
de este proceso que le abrirán a
Velázquez y cuáles son los detalles del
caso
Bueno estamos el contexto de Guatemala
es que se está desarrollando una un
sistema que está protegiendo
criminales procesados y se está
persiguiendo a jueces Fiscales Y en este
caso al comisionado Iván Velázquez
estamos en un proceso más amplio donde
hay más de 35 Fiscales y jueces
perseguidos por hacer su trabajo y en
este caso se suma a este primer indicio
de investigación contra el comisionado
aquí hay que recordar que la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad Es un
órgano de Naciones Unidas Es un órgano
que tiene toda la protección diplomática
y todas las actuaciones que se han hecho
han sido conforme a ley es decir esta es
una denuncia espuria es una denuncia que
lo único pretende es
argumentar dentro de una serie de
acciones que se están haciendo para
liberar delincuentes aquí el caso
específico el caso odebrech la fiscalía
primero canceló Los acuerdos de
colaboración para proteger a los
criminales que están siendo perseguidos
entonces lo que estamos viendo Es una
persecución a a los operadores a los
fiscales Y en este caso al comisionado
para proteger a personas que sí están
involucrados en el caso y concretamente
que tiene la fiscalía guatemalteca en
contra de Iván Velázquez
bueno es en realidad está así es una una
operación política no tiene nada porque
todo lo que se hizo se hizo conforme a
derecho con forma de ley y conforme a
los acuerdos internacionales que se
firmaron es decir esto es otra más de
las denuncias espurias que ha estado
haciendo esta fiscalía para perseguir a
jueces Fiscales y personas que dedicaron
su vida a perseguir verdaderos
criminales